una de las cosas que hace blitch tan
entretenido es su gran cantidad de
habilidades y poderes bastante
originales y variados tienes espadas que
te chupan la vida otras que te
emborrachan e incluso unas que Ay [__]
no sé te
desintegran yo no lo entiendo el punto
es que hay cientos de habilidades tanto
creativas como ridículamente fuertes
pero así como en las series se leerán
habilidades rompe madres a sus
personajes más importantes a otros se
les mando un poquito al [__] y se les
dio las habilidades más inútiles y
ridículas que pudieron pensar
ya exploramos hace tiempo una lista de
los chica y más útiles y poderosos que
hay en la serie pero ahora es tiempo de
ver la otra cara de la moneda y analizar
las espadas con las habilidades más
criminalmente malas e inútiles que hay
Hola Perdona que te interrumpa solo
venía rápidamente a decirte que la
función de miembros del Canal ya está
habilitada por si quieres apoyarme un
poco más Y de paso ganar acceso a emojis
personalizados menciones en los videos y
otras cosas geniales eso era todo
volvamos al video ahora al realizar esta
lista tuve que dejar a algunos por fuera
debido a que no se sabe nada de dichas
habilidades por ejemplo llegué a
considerar azakibe y su espada chistosa
o esa cosa fea que tiene hisane pero
dado que sólo aparecieron durante medio
segundo y nunca más se les volvió a ver
prefiero dejarlos afuera de la lista
habiendo dicho eso vamos a ver cinco de
los peores chica y de todo Bleach
antes de comenzar con la lista siento la
necesidad de incluir a un personaje como
mención honorífica y ese personaje es
ichigo Ya sé ya sé antes de que insultes
a todo mi linaje en los comentarios
escúchame ichigo es el personaje
principal de la serie Así que cuando ves
a todos teniendo sus habilidades
mamadísimas y variadas comienzas a
generar expectativas sobre Qué clase de
poderes locos tendrá protagonista y
cuando llega el momento tiene otra
espada más grande está horrible a ver
Hay que ser objetivos Yo sé que todos
amamos ahí chico y eso pero esto es un
cuchillo de carnicero que lanza
brillitos de todas las habilidades que a
ti te cubo pudo haberle dado a su
protagonista decidió darle los poderes
más genéricos que pudo encontrar Además
de que ichigo se la pasa usando su banca
y en el 90% de sus batallas Así que su
shika y rara vez sirve de algo
solía ser en papel uno de los mejores
que había el concepto era simple si te
tocaba dos veces te mueres era el arma
perfecta para alguien como soy phone
algo pequeño ágil y poderoso O al menos
lo era hasta que llegó eizen cuando soy
font cometió el gravísimo error de
atacar los pectorales de aysén nos
enteramos de mano de él mismo que susica
y tiene una debilidad si su oponente es
más fuerte que ella su habilidad ya no
servirá para un [__] lo que quiere
decir que solo funciona con enemigos que
tengan menos energía que soy phone Si
ella quiere pelear con alguien poderoso
pues mejor a pataditas porque su chica y
no funcionará como si esto no fuera
suficiente en el arco de la guerra nos
enteramos de otra de sus debilidades Y
es que si su sica y no puede perforar o
atravesar a su oponente no va a servir
de nada como vimos con Virgin Nine que
al ser de un metal demasiado fuerte no
lo pudo atravesar y su habilidad fue
completamente negada Ven a lo que me
refiero la habilidad de susumevachi es
genial pero dejó de funcionar contra el
99% de los personajes en blitch de nada
te sirve tener una habilidad rompe
madres si no funciona contra nadie
komamura es un personaje muy interesante
y su espada tiene una habilidad igual de
interesante cuando komara libera su sika
y su espada no cambian lo absoluto Lo
que sucede es que puede manifestar
partes gigantes de su megazor para
imitar sus movimientos y pelear junto a
él esto le otorga un gran poder
destructivo y una Fuerza bruta increíble
Pero entonces por qué estar aquí te
estarás preguntando Bueno mira el tamaño
de esa [__] puedo ver esa espada a 348
metros de distancia mientras comamos una
me ataca con esa espada tan gorda me da
tiempo suficiente para hacerme el
desayuno ver One Piece completa hacer la
tesis de la universidad y ahí sí evadir
el ataque lo único que te permite Esta
chicai es golpear muy fuerte no puedes
cortar con precisión y pelear
discretamente es una habilidad poderosa
pero lenta y por lo que vimos en la
serie poco efectiva
aquí decidí dejar un doble empate entre
dos de las espadas más inútiles que vi
en la serie y son Fuji kuyaku el shikai
falso de yumichica y kubiorochi el
horrible Sí que de hiori mapache que
porquería la razón por la que están tan
abajo en la lista Es simple no hace
absolutamente nada no ganas rasos láser
como ichigo llamas o alguna otra
habilidad lo único que logran
activándolo es cambiar su espada normal
por otra arma un poco más grande y
estorbosa nada más Y mira que esto es un
pecado del que muchas otras armas pecan
en Bleach con Fuji kuyaku Aunque
entiendo que es un chica y falso y la
idea yume chica es hacerlo mucho más
adecuado para el combate cercano y todo
eso La verdad es que no es más que
cuatro hojas muy afiladas tiene poco
alcance y hace lo mismo que la espada
original Solo que peor y con hiori pues
es una enorme y pesa da Sierra Eso es
todo
y kaku es un tipo fuerte que le encanta
pelear pero [__] sí que le fue mal con
sus habilidades el chica y de ikaku es
sólo un palito que corta es decir en un
universo en donde los personajes
convierten sus espadas en un [__] dragón
de hielo o miles de cuchillas asesinas
tener tres palitos con un cuchillo al
borde no me parece muy útil que digamos
sí puedes separarse en tres partes para
tomar por sorpresa a su enemigo Y sí
tiene una pomadita chistosa para detener
el sangrado de su usuario en caso de
emergencia pero eso es todo esta chica
además de ser una simple lanza es
bastante frágil y se rompe con
frecuencia lo que deja y caku desarmado
es un sica y simple débil y frágil que
no le otorga un gran beneficio a su
usuario Así que
si una [__]
el shikate de umaeda se puede definir
Sencillamente como una bolita
sosteniendo otra bolita
No ya en serio el chicle domaeda es para
mí el peor que hay este al igual que
otras armas de las que ya hemos hablado
no tiene otra habilidad más que
convertir su espada original en otra
arma mucho menos versátil Pero entonces
por qué este es peor bueno los otros al
menos tienen más fuerza o funcionan como
Cuatro espadas y con ikaku su chica Y al
menos es algo ligero que le da bastante
velocidad y versatilidad a sus
movimientos pero con omaeda solo le
otorga desventajas pues su chica y
convierte en su espada en esta enorme
bola de demolición con Púas saliendo de
su exterior es absurdamente grande y
pesada lo que hace el Ya de por sí lento
de madera aún más lento no se puede
mover rápido sus ataques tardan un
montón y son poco precisos y al ser tan
pesado se llega a fallar su ataque lo
deja expuesto a una patadita en las
costillas además de que ni siquiera
Parece ser resistente como aparenta
porque la primera vez que vemos Esta
cosa fea y llegó la destruye de un solo
golpe digan lo que digan este es para mí
el peor si que hay de todo Bleach
sé que ya es algo que deberían saber
Pero esto es una opinión personal es lo
que yo Considero que son los peores
chica en Bleach sé que tal vez tú tienes
una lista diferente y me gustaría verla
en los comentarios Dime para ti Cuál es
el peor chica y de toda la serie
eventualmente ya miraremos los peores
Banks también pero todo su tiempo y
antes de que me lo digan sí sé que les
dé un vídeo de los bancais más poderosos
en Bleach pero ténganme paciencia la
universidad está una [__] les prometo
que voy a tratar de hacer estos vídeos
bueno todos en general mucho más seguido
voy a ser mi mejor esfuerzo de momento
si quieren ver más vídeos relacionados a
Bleach o alguna otra serie de igual
manera Déjenme sus ideas en los
comentarios Síganme en mis redes apoya
el canal Y bueno ya sabes el resto hasta
la próxima
[Música]